von daher das ist das jetzt eigentlich
eine kiste sekt euch hallo ich in meiner
liegt eine freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer asia games folge
zusammen mit ganz ganz vielen anderen
youtube an und um gespielten den werde
ich sofort töten wenn ich den in die
finger bekommen
wir haben komplett leeres inventar das
ist eine map gebaut von luke place und
ein paar anderen irgendwas mit tomate
habe ich gerade gehört sich vor bock auf
tomaten jedenfalls ich bin eigentlich
klappt hier gleich also ich nicht
sondern für die fans das glaub ich
jemand ja das ist lukas kohler namen
übrigens man durfte minimiert benutzen
ich war ehrlich gesagt für zuvor die
rhein zu packen ob die feine mich drin
habe ich raus gepackt weil es immer noch
ein bisschen hakt und ich schreib mal
ganz kurz
wann geht es denn
ok also sehen
in 98 ich werde bald randale machen mein
essen steht oben auf dem herd deswegen
muss mich über ein 4 3 2 1
wtf tag über geschichte der ist ein glas
kaputt gemacht das darf man nicht das
einzige was ich habe es ein gebiet mehr
hab ich nicht wow
es ist jetzt echt eine super ausbeute
gewesen muss echt sagen zu penny bei den
hunger games bekommen ich weiß du ich
habe überhaupt kein plan wohin die kiste
ist aber dass um gespielt so viel weiß
ich ich bin direkt bezahlen dass da
hinten sind schon welche bei den
komischen häusern ist doch total unfair
da ist um gespielt
hier spielt die schwelle die stadt denn
er nicht ich kriege werte sind auch noch
leute hinter mir oder so wie sich das
anhört so ich werde mal hier rein gehen
euro dazu
das auch zu kann ich nicht in die hosen
jetzt auch zu ihr toll
ja das bringt selbst total wenn ich da
nicht hochkam
okay man ich hab gar keine sachen er das
selber richtig geil jetzt hier läuft
richtig gut für mich muss hier irgendwie
hochkommen oder da irgendwie rein oder
so ich will einfach von ich will so gar
keinen gegner total angst nein also ich
muss irgendwie sachen kriegen oder
hinten sieht sky das web ist in der
beschreibung alle anderen mitspieler
sind auch ein app beschreibung cvp los
scheiße stimmt war die ganze zeit hinter
mir zum unsichtbar als krank oder so ok
es kam mir so jetzt muss ich ja noch
irgendwie hoch kommen so ich werde mich
dahin nicht wetter hin
schwimmen
unter wasser natürlich damit man sieht
ja nicht so dass man den namen sie keine
quatsch oder hinter dessen name auf axt
auch nicht erst all dies nicht so
ich muss irgendwie kommen did it again
ich werde hier schon längst in so ein
typ und hat mir alle kästen geklappt das
noch ob und wenn ja ob irgendwo es dann
ist nie gut mit dem was nicht gut
kirschen essen will
und der mich tötet dann bin ich aber
böse
zunächst wenn man dass ich nicht mal in
die kiste findet ist
wow
das ist jetzt mal richtig geil was hier
drin ist freue ich mich richtig freue
ich mich auch richtig
ich sehe schon kommen das noch gleich
irgendwie neben es nicht
nein ich kann laufen ist der name leider
ist kein name
ok gleich kann ich nicht mehr laufen das
heißt ich da oben ist noch ob das da
oben drin okay gut dann laufe ich
einfach weg und versuch größtenteils zu
überleben das ist mein ziel
bisher läuft das recht scheiße weil ich
spiele die map gerade wirklich zum
allerersten mal ich habe nicht mehr den
trailer gesehen das ist hältst du die
sache
naja muss er jetzt nur irgendwie von
dort weg kommen wenn ich hab ein steinen
und einen stock stein stock jedenfalls
brauche ich noch ein stein damit ich mir
so ein komisches ding instruments machen
kann
in wer schon tot
doch noch einen stock damit ich mir so
ein einsteiger mit ich mir ein schwert
machen kann oder was kann ich sonst mit
diesen fünf sachen da was ist das hier
ist doch wieder nix nix und wieder nix
so liest darf man ja kaputt machen hatte
er gesagt stimmt das stand ja sogar
allerdings bestimmt habe ich schon viele
gesehen weil man liest also leafs weins
et cetera darf man kaputt machen
bocker ich habe gute sachen aber ich
brauche halt ne workbench ok workbench
war da oben zwar gerade ich auch schon
so weit scheint menowin 31 krass ich
brauche noch ein stein
jetzt mal ganz
ich kann mich hier raus ich kann mir
nicht mehr aus
doch ich kann es ja mal was auf
raus bin ich
dass ein schwein zu essen brauche ich
zurzeit aber erstmal nicht
einzig was ich auch ist ein stein
ein test oder gold
die bernstein waldstein schwertes als
gold
allgemein ähnliche sachen für mich
irgendwie töten sollte dann bitte nicht
norwalk welcher tötet jeden der gebiet
dass er nach jahren als sehr gut
stress
sie liebe es nichts kann man nicht
irgendwie dieses verpackte dem ziel hoch
kommen oder so ich trau mich nicht
aussuchen zu laufen so viele leute
einmal fragen werden die kirsten ans von
irgendwem aufgefüllt
dann haben wir schon voll rein
geschissen darf man alles kaputt machen
die nachfrage eher wie will man
instanziert einkommen das wgm floh
die hälfte der leute kenne ich hier
wirklich nicht als zu schlecht ist
zuschüsse erster oben
er schlägt irgendwas was nicht existiert
doch der dunst dateien unsichtbarkeit
rang 8 hat eine kuh geschlagen oder so
jetzt merke ich das könne so
seine mutter gleich irgendwann rein
platzt oder so
bin mir aber nicht sicher oder solches
risiko gehen komme ich gern risiko ich
will jetzt hier irgendjemanden wird
finden ich mir jetzt auch total
langweilig wenn ich einfach nur
umstellung gar nichts machen da wird es
werden wahrscheinlich schon alle kisten
wochen fallen darf man kaputt machen
keine frage man gefangen ist es mal
gefangen
als 18 das habe ich aber nicht gesehen
ross
da sind auch schon alle hoch geschwommen
oder auch gekraxelt oder hubert borgert
und werde ich nicht trainieren blick ist
eine rüstung things aber wie gesagt ich
brauche ein stein
ich verstecke mich jetzt grade mal
irgendwo dann rufe ich in meiner mutter
die salze stören
ich hoffe mich seht ihr keiner wenn ich
getötet werde dann bin ich selbst schuld
ok gleich wartet vielleicht hätte mich
auch nochmal klar blanc
so
wahrscheinlich habe ich keinen cut
gemacht nicht vergessen sondern weil es
irgendwie recht schnell ging und es wird
macht was soll ich denn hin ich halte da
sieht heftig aus ja wie schon gesagt ich
brauche ein stein rheingold ich kann mir
so schreibe ich lebe noch
weil das wundert mich gerade recht warum
bin ich mal am leben ich hab mich fast
nix ohne chichi
doch wirklich
irgendwie drauf oder so entschuldigung
nicht danach aus
er war doch auch schon 110 oder
okay was haben wir denn hier workbench
offen ich brauche ein stein wie schon
gesagt warum kann mir den gefallen tun
gibt man minecraft gott ist auch nix
drauf auf dem ding
egal ob eine rüstung
hör auf das wollte ich wiederum nicht da
kann ich auch mal reingucken hier so
einfach mal obwohl da wahrscheinlich
nichts oder ist gar nichts sondern
versuche ich jetzt mal dieses komische
ding hier zu erkranken
da hinten ist so ein tor aber nur dort
schon drin und dann das ding kommt man
nur durch den mund dann nach einer
wahrscheinlich war doch auch schon als
ich das schon die map ist nicht danach
aufgebaut das ansporn in der umgebung
richtig geile sachen sind blogs bleibt
der sachen ich nicht
that means ich habe so gut wie perfekt
hilfe hilfe
lasst mich in ruhe ich geb dir mein
ganzes money ich habe gesagt jetzt musst
du
so war keine ahnung wo er jetzt ist kein
plan wo ich jetzt her laufen soll
ich laufe einfach hier durch den wald
ich glaube die ganze hänge ich hab das
gefühl ist direkt hinter mir oh gott ich
sehe da hinten die ganzen leute die da
oben drin hocken
sind im internet kein ende mehr
auch sehr sehr äußerst klug formieren
lässt sich hier die komplett
beleuchteten wege langlauf so dass mich
auch ja jeder sieht
so ich laufe einfach mal so ein bisschen
rum
vielleicht ist hier noch irgendwas drin
was zu einer vergessen hat was
wahrscheinlich eh nicht so ist
ich weiß nicht wie hoch ich mich aber
wann kann ich hoch was mir allerdings
auch nichts bringt glaube ich auch aus
schmerz
ich sehe aber auch keine person mehr
irgendwie heißt sind wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr so viele am leben ich bin ein
einsamer tod irgendwo runtergefallen
fragt sich in frage ich mich nur dass
alle hier sind ja wirklich überall
monster das sehr blöd cartel wilson
schwert wie jetzt handeln die da schon
nein
gut kann
naja kuba zu reisen
was tut man nicht alles zusammen drei
schnitzel
ich sehe schon kommen ich sterbe gleich
schaffe ich sie nicht mehr die
einfachsten blöcke hier hoch zu springen
auch kein plant lange ich habe schon am
leben bin wie lange ich aufnehme oder
ähnliches von oben sieht aber auch krass
aus ich weiß ich bin nicht so der beste
der euch die besten games liefern kann
da gibt es bessere definitiv alle sind
besser als ich es einfach so was sagt
eigentlich noch hier was eigentlich noch
so können wir mal wieder machen denn
auch hier seit wow und immer noch da
seid also noch guckt schreibt mir bitte
lava in die kommentare
dann sehe ich das immer wieder noch
zuschauen das interessiert mich echt
nicht dass hier gleich noch eine falle
tappen sie deswegen gebe ich hier gerade
besonders 8 wisst ihr der gangart hat
ihre total gebracht immer wenn ich diese
musik an stimme fühle ich mich wie
indiana jones und denkt dann soll ich
kann ja alles nieder und dann ist das
gegenteil der fall nicht voll auf die
fresse ich würde das geld in den chat
schreiben an ban will ich vom wasserfall
runterfallen
oh wunder gefallen was öffentlich da
hochschule wasser
wenn ich ihn wohnraum
wow das hat es gebracht das hat
definitiv gebracht ich weiß dass da oben
nichts ist von daher gehe ich jetzt
einfach wieder runter obwohl da könnte
ich mir das nur noch jan luca und ich
bgm flomo jung sehr onic ich hatte
soviel ist sicher ich habe keinen grund
meine ja toll also wahrscheinlich auch
noch retten und den chat irgendwie
ausgemacht dass ich mich aber schon cool
nein also ich werde so oder so verpacken
ich hatte nur noch keine eins gegen eins
situation die das irgendwie unter beweis
stellen konnte dass ich schlecht bin
von daher was ist das jetzt eigentlich
so eine kiste
legt euch schickt euch man das kino
grasen alles ab letzten schweine herr
kong graf hannover leitet die immer und
ist nix das nun aber irgendwie zur
beleuchtung oder so so sehr war dieser
scheiß strömungen hat
sicherheitsbedenken das angefangen zu
brennen
nicht aus wenn da irgendwas hinter
obwohl hinter dem wasserfall
schade ich dachte zebras oder so das
meine ich
blattmann
nein lass mich in ruhe lasst mich in
ruhe auf
lauf lauf mein minecraft charakter lauf
lauf um dein leben im wahrsten sinn des
wortes lauf orff actebis directly hinter
mir das jetzt natürlich eine sackgasse
ruhig rein gelaufen bin ich hoffe jetzt
einfach die ganze zeit um sein haus rum
wenn ich das kann irgendwie okay
erkennt man okay wir sehen uns dann
irgendwann anders mal wieder ich gehe es
erstmal schön was fressen und dann ja
wie immer bewährt nicht geht ich weiß
nicht vielleicht hab ich nun folgen ich
glaube ja nicht wir sehen uns dann wenn
jetzt mal wieder wie immer bewerten
nicht vergessen und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal
und erst recht doch mein gott
ok ich nehme wieder mit dx tore auf ganz
einfach er hat einfach die stimme von
urlaub nicht mit aufgezeichnet naja ich
habe eigentlich gerade gesagt dass ich
endlich kleinere momenten dran packe
habe ich allerdings doch gemacht weil
ich war nach der letzten alleinigen
runde essen und danach habe ich dann
gesehen dass die einzelrunde noch im
laufen bankkarte hat das dann gewonnen
und dann haben wir halt hier diese
doppel runde gemacht und ihr seht man
hier die erste entscheidende situation
und zwar habe ich dort eine kiste
gefunden da oben in diesem dienst aber
nicht uns alles gekrallt
und ich hab nur noch dann so gut wie
alles abgegeben weil ich selber nicht zu
der novelle kindern das wisst ihr seht
ihr guckt habe ich eigentlich immer
alles gegeben was ich habe außerdem
werden die brote ich kommentiere das
gerade alles ein bisschen nach na ja und
man macht playmate play und prime wir
sind einfach unter gesprochen die an
handel
nachher mein partner warten ob steht
auch in der beschreibung zusammen mit
allen anderen leuten dabei waren köpfen
hier so ein bisschen durch den wald hat
dann da war so ein loch da der eine
kiste voller sitzt kann eigentlich ganz
gut damit nach kommentieren weil wir das
gerade ist gezockt haben wir sind werdet
ihr noch wesentlichen wald gelaufen mit
gott die kiste zu finden und in die mail
place und zu töten zu können wenn sie
mir in so ein komisches gebilde
reingelaufen kontemplatives zeugs dabei
weise komische löcher fallen
nun hat sich dann eine kiste gekrallt da
waren aber allerdings auch nicht so
geile sachen drin war glaube ich april
um so aus alles drin aber ich schon zehn
brote in der kiste folgen gefunden hatte
naja sind wir dann halt die hoch
gelaufen ich bin so klug und feldern
hier erstmal runter da halb tot oder
fast ganz tot oder die einfach runter
gelaufen dann auf ihn gewartet da kann
man auch runter hat aber auch nichts
geiles gefunden ziehen wir ein paar
pfeile sondern lediglich weil ja stimmt
dann haben wir da hinten diese
plattformen gesehen da oben degradiert
kurz eingeblendet gesehen trage ich auch
gerade hin wo ich in der letzten folge
schon da wo allerdings die kiste leer
war
was sie zu dem zeitpunkt allerdings
nicht wusste ist dass dort eine andere
plattform ist das eine andere plattform
ist und da es gar nix drauf gewesen also
nicht mal eine kiste
warum haben dann gesehen das gameplay
und miami sind dann dahin gelaufen
also ich wollte erstmal corner bisher
direkt hin ich wollte erstmal kommt eine
kiste ist da war keine kiste ich mich an
voll aufgeregt so wir laufen dann hier
umsehen die sind besser ausgerüstet als
wir ich so ja kaum mit schiebt man
keinen stress in mir dass man mich
einfach so da geht dann einfach mal
direkt runter und verpackt also seht ihr
zum chatten oder post lane aber kaum
alleine bringt es das auch nicht dass
wir auch töten und dann war's auch schon
vorbei
nun war wir dann hier noch in diesem
komischen bedrock blog gebäude wir waren
halt die ersten die gestorben sind zwar
recht witzig damals sache gedacht komm
jetzt schon so gestorben sind wir
wenigstens doch eine person dann haben
wir diesen felix da getötet
und na ja das war es auch schon mit den
baseler games also man kann nur noch
dass er dabei war wasser setzt nach
kommentieren muss tutorial city extorre
wird wahrscheinlich schon kommen nur ich
hab das halt falsch eingestellt gehabt
weil vor jetzt auch funktioniert und da
etwas und ich würde einfach sagen wie
immer wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
hoch wenn sich gefordert um runter kommt
einfach eure meinung zu der met in die
kommentare schreiben
sonst linkliste zu allen leuten ist eben
der beschreibung und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal